[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans sa occasions d'abord une pensée
pour notre collègue maurizio alto
surtout qu'il se soigne bien et nous
reviennent rapidement l'invité ce matin
c'est louis joseph manscour bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen ps et
membre du comité de soutien à manuel
valls l'un des sept candidats aux
primaires du ps alors votre candidat
peut dire qu'il est déjà un modeste que
manuel valls a déclaré ce matin le
journal le parisien qu'il n'est pas le
favori de la primaire il dit ça dans le
journal pour dire que c'est comme au
foot un peu il vaut mieux mettre la
pression des adversaires le problème
c'est qu'un sondage qu'il faut
évidemment prendre avec précaution bien
lui donner raison puisque il arriverait
en tête du premier tour mais serait
battu au second tour par arnaud
montebourg 53% contre 47% alors on
parlait tout à l'heure des courses
refait une petite analogie est ce que
votre poulain est en train de se faire
distancer
alors est ce grâce à permettez que je
souhaite pour sacrifier à la tradition
des meilleurs voeux aux martiniquais aux
monty nicaise et puis deux pour des
trinités écoutez moi je pense qu'il
faudrait pas non plus qu'on soit obsédé
par les sondages nous avons vu ce que ça
a donné pour d'autres élections
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas encore eu de
débat télévisé il ya beaucoup de
programmes étaient serrés le premier
c'est jeudi et il doit présenter son
programme concernant les outre mer
mercredi donc je pense qu'il est
prématuré de parler de celui qui sera
devant ou qui vient après ce qui est
important pour nous aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir quel programme et qu'il devra
mettre un neveu pour défendre les
intérêts de la france et des tirs et des
outre-mer s'arrête une indication quant
même
oui c'est une indication je pense que
c'est sûr vous inquiétez vous pas sans
écouter géré poulain ça m'inquiète de ce
havre ac il peut être ne pas être là
parce que je pense que c'est le l'homme
de la situation ce moment écoutez nous
nous irons même qui très difficile dans
le monde voyez bien l'europe ce qui se
passe le bre site le problème des
migrants et des problèmes de sécurité
tous les problèmes avec monsieur poutine
monsieur 30 qui vient d'être élu il fau
de quelqu'un d'expérience il faut d'un
homme et je pense que manuel valls qui
fut ministre de l'intérieur est aussi
premier ministre est en capacité de
pouvoir affronter tous ces défis manuel
valls qui a quand même un bilan à
défendre celui quelque part de françois
hollande à milan qui n'est pas
spécialement brillant non écoutez moi je
pense très sincèrement qu'on parle de
bilan il faudra bien qu on sait ce qu'il
veut et il faudra bien mots manquants et
justement c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles je le soutiens parce que dès
lors où le président a renoncé à être
président à être candidat à sa propre
succession et dc5 il fallait bien qu'il
y ait quelqu'un plus défendre le bilan
qui est globalement positive je ne dis
pas qu'il ya pas d homme nombre mais
globalement positif et j'espère positif
écoutez moi si je prends le serait ce
que je pense aussi qu'on a du mal à dire
qu'on ne voit pas peut-être que le tort
de 2,2 de françois hollande c'est
n'avoir pas dit quand il est arrivé que
la situation qu'il ya qu'il avait trouvé
n'était pas celle à laquelle ils
espéraient et que par conséquent c'est
une somme aux besoins de communication
qui doit fallu corriger à l'époque
maintenant c'est fait c'est fait en quoi
manuel valls va être différent vois en
quoi donc on peut attendre un changement
de sa part aujourd'hui s'il est désignée
candidate pour pour le ps vous savez
lorsqu'on est candidat et qu'on est aux
affaires ce n'est pas la même chose
moi j'aime bien l'habitude de parler
comme exemple je fus premier adjoint au
maire de trinité pendant des années bon
je respecte j'ai respecté mon
prédécesseur dont je lui dois beaucoup
mais dans le même temps quand je suis
arrivé j'ai donné ma propre vision avec
une autre politique une autre manière
d'appréhender des choses et c'est normal
qu'on puisse le faire
mais concernant pas en plus outre mer
qu'est ce qui nous dit qu'à pas venir
nous dire encore voilà on va mettre
tendant veloppe temps de fonds pour
faire ceci cela mais finalement ça va
hein ça ne va déboucher sur rien encore
non je ne pense pas qu'il faut est faux
pas d'un vrai plan pour nos régions mais
bien sûr mais il le plein et ligier
et vous allez entendre attendent
mercredi mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que c'est le gouvernement de manuel
valls quand même qui a aidé à élaborer
d'égalité réelle du projet d'égalité
réelle qu'on a voté donc c'est la
première fois il ya une volonté de faire
en sorte qu' il faut essayer de gommer
quelques inégalités que l'on rencontre
dans tous les domaines mais il s'agit
pas de distribuer des milliards et des
milliards
même s'il s'est engagé à a donné un
milliard sur cinq d'euros sur cinq ans
pour les outre-mer pour permettre de
d'aboutir d'arriver jusqu'à cette
égalité à laquelle je n'ai de faire
allusion
vous dites que manuel valls et le
modernisme du ps ah oui oui écoutez vous
savez qu'est ce que c'est que ça
démocrate et qu'est ce qui ce qui
casserait démocrate c'est avant tout
celui qui sans renier les valeurs
dessous du social disney valeurs
d'égalité de fraternité et bien essaie
de faire bouger la société
mais oui c'est un des formateurs et
c'est bien pour cela que je le soutiens
c'est pourtant ce que m non non je
considère qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est qu'au plus au plan
humain on puisse quand même essayer
d'atténuer les inégalités en prenant des
mesures concernant l'éducation la
situation sociale qu'on puisse
accompagner aussi les les
socioprofessionnels c'est ça est très
formateur le monde n'a changé on peut
pas être comme en 1980 à l'époque de
françois mitterrand donc comment on fait
campagne face à des martiniquais une
série par des augmentations des prix des
carburants un chômage qui qui perdure
comment on fait campagne
oui qu'est ce qu'on leur dit vous n'avez
pas dit on à lisser le contexte oui
alors comment dans ce contexte le
contexte est extrêmement difficile il
faut le dire mais ne comptez que ce
n'est pas ce moment est unique
vous savez que je suis en europe je fais
75 busan monte en europe
je peux vous dire que la situation est
dure et peu partout en europe mais aussi
dans d'autres pays et que par conséquent
il va falloir qu'on puisse ramener en
fassent des sacrifices et pour faire
avancer des choses dont ceci dit vous
êtes seul ans martin nos connaissances
et on a demandé saint-frédéric berry a
pas d'autres comités de soutien dont
comment on fait campagne sans solde en
marge et à dire non non je veux dire
qu'il ya qu un seul comité de soutien
aujourd'hui à manuel valls
mais il peut pas avoir plusieurs comités
non non je ne prie pas pour les autres
candidats dont quelque part vous avez
vous avez un boulevard ici en tout cas
en tout cas il n'y a pas de diktat ou
chez nous s'il n'y a pas d'autre pour
l'instant je dis bien pour l'instant
d'autres représentants d'autres
candidats mais je trouve ça dommage mais
personnellement je suis pour une action
menée en faveur de de manuel valls est
ce que nous sommes en train de faire
alors quelque part si votre candidat
n'est pas désigné quel serait votre
attitude le président intitulé je suis
socialiste
vous le savez c'est craindre une
discipline de parti
non nous avons une préférence mais je
vais pas jeter l'anathème sur des autres
candidats
les autres sont bons quand ils sentent
le bon candidat mais aujourd'hui je
soutiens manuel valls 6 2 mais est ce
que je ne souhaite pas lier il ne devait
pas être élu candidat représentant des
soucis aux primaires je soutiendrai le
candidat que la majorité a choisi c'est
ça la démocratie
alors une question qui concerne macro et
mélenchon deux anciens ubs quelque part
je crois n'a jamais été enfin bon oui
enfin mais il a été aujourd'hui en tout
cas allons donc
on présente monsieur macron comme le
troisième homme éventuellement mêmes qui
pourrait battre
manuel valls un commentaire sur ça on
est en train de créer un phénomène
je les médias et tous deux créé le
phénomène le phénomène mâcon alors
écoutez je pense que il a beaucoup de
qualités monsieur mâcon mais je pense
que comme je vous disais au débat il
faut avoir l'expérience il faut avoir
il exerce à s'inscrire dans le temps
dans l'épreuve du pouvoir au niveau du
quotidien lorsqu'on est élu
on met la main dans le cambouis
lorsqu'on est maires conseillers
municipaux députés
bref je crois qu'il faut le faire au me
semble-t-il que je ne dis pas qu'il n'a
pas les qualités requises
mais dans ce contexte là je pense que on
verra bien que l'homme de la situation
c'est encore manuel valls
une question qui concerne aussi jean luc
mélenchon là aussi un commentaire sur
son sol ni présence et les bons scores
qui réalise aussi dans les sondages cela
oui dans les sondages son retour dans
les salles à mieux que certains
candidats ps
est ce que pour vous c'est une menace à
prendre très au sérieux à main jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui oui c'est une
menace par rapport au candidat au choix
que je fais c'est une menace mais je
vous dis je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on
fasse quand même un peu comme le
parisien icône évite de commenter les
sondages les sondages les sondages alors
qu il n'y a pas encore eu de débat il ya
beaucoup d'explications ya progrès de
présentation de programmes
alors aujourd'hui ainsi vous pouvez même
si c'est mercredi effectivement ils nous
ont convaincus que le programme de
randonnées en détail bonne et quand même
quelques grandes lignes un petit peu de
ce que pourrait faire ou de ce que
désire faire un manuel valls pour la
martinique ou plus largement pour
l'outre-mer non je pense qu'il a on a
fait voter son gouvernement fait voter
disons la loi sur l'égalité réelle il
faut asseoir ses propositions de magna
traiter les traits nets pour l'affirmer
il y a aussi un projet d' il a déjà
proposé un milliard pour les doigts mais
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure il ya une
simplification aussi de la loi de
défiscalisation pour permettre de mieux
prendre en compte la réalité des petites
entreprises des pme mais aussi la fédé a
des filiales écoles les filières aussi
de la pêche
je crois qu'il ya aussi une volonté
d'aider d'eau de recruter aussi des
policiers des et mais aussi des
enseignants
je pense que cette politique doit le
temps d'expliquer at il expliqué très
bientôt
mercredi je les dis et bien vous verrez
bien qu'il a invoquant pour l'outre-mer
et il faut reconnaître aussi que c'est
quelqu'un qui est bien venu ici qui
porte beaucoup dé tirer au soufre mais
et qu'il a montré déjà même au niveau du
gouvernement
joseph manscour je vous remercie vous
êtes membre du comité de soutien à
manuel valls c'est la fin de cinq ans
d'inertie devenu dans nos studios
récit des lecteurs